hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay we're just gonna
learn the thumb here I'll tell you ah
take that those guys this week to get
for standing in the way ruin way what
hey Lydia you Liam press yeah huh you
impressed Lydia I can tell you're
impressed
what oh yeah okay ready
hopeless Oh BAM on the best off Lydia
yeah contain your excitement at how
great I am
one more yes I do
once more I know come on
okay all right get ready Duffy home
there we go am I done now impressive can
I go on my way or thumb is precise no
joke show great promise dragon ball
better than anyone else you want say
differently yeah Lydia in the courtyard
okay what monster boy
I will not he will follow me this way
yeah I follow myself no one else Oh what
oh you're cold probably yeah I kind of
took off your armor and fur there that's
okay you're tough right Lydia right
Lydia you're tough you look tough and so
pretty there he is
come here come on get it over with
bori come on bori okay alright put away
my axe for now
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do oh you're
over here waiting for me
fantastic story excellent
most excellent whoo uh-huh gimme suck it
into my brain fantastic
I hear it I'm staring right at it it's
like all up in my brain whirlwind sprint
rush to give
I don't mean to act forward here but I
mean I actually like this story stuff I
don't mind it at all but I know some
people out there probably get forward by
it okay now let me favorite it child's
favorite and switch to it hostel wolf
God will demonstrate whirlwind sprint
I don't need it demonstrated what this
was like shoot you for it I think master
body mas de bourree Beck's
won wow he almost went off the mountain
stand next to me mas de bourree will
open the gate use your whirlwind sprint
to pass through before it closes uh-huh
really I can't couldn't go around PAH
boom yeah best oh I'm so great Oh Liddy
I know you're running over to me because
I'm so across story of a new film is
astonishing yes it is heard the stories
of the abilities of yeah born but to see
it from myself I'd be astonished too if
I wasn't so confident in myself
Thank You Watson acts you are now
retrieve the Horn of your gun when
you're in wind collar on his tomb okay
shouldn't pain Austin Graff remain true
to the way of the voice you will return
I got it okay hey well right in just a
second
okay I'll figure out that later if you
want them lower then this isn't the
let's play for you because I'm not gonna
be rushing up little or I'm just gonna
be getting through the game let me copy
something in Cavan lore but I'm talking
about all the backlog still wait where
am I going all the stories you know this
Skyrim is so rich with story that is
it's not just about on the gameplay but
you can play it either way and I'm just
gonna try to get through the story
because otherwise this series would last
like ten billion years okay I'm going
somewhere where am I going bear him hi
going where's my journal say the horn of
jurgen wind color okay from his tomb in
Ostend Grob wait wait was that in the
marshes of how John to mark March
mark mark March there it is there it is
all the way up there hot damn well
anyway let me stop in it River would get
some potions stop in it the other place
that I can't remember what it is
get some potions and then be on my merry
way
pots nighttime douche douches
Phaethon white and then tie them to
stump instant frostbite spider what are
you talking about kid that's pretty
morbid yeah whatever I don't have time
for you kids I'm off on a manly adult
adventure I'm 23 now I'm gonna be doing
knee and keep sure thing are yours for a
day thank you
all right off we go where is this room
Lydia oh oh we're gonna have to snuggle
up real tight in here all right Larry 10
hours should be enough he's now mid US
20th of last seed oh yeah okay let's go
Lydia all right now I'm sure the traitor
has some sort of potions available sure
how much though and I got some crap that
I need to offload anyway cuz I'm poor I
am great because I wanted you to have
some way to thank you
token of my affection what don't power
engaged you're nothing they just want to
give me crap all over the place that's
weird oh ma take a look he's got a crush
on me and so does she anyway God peril
here I don't need the iron boots and
gauntlets keep those give her those
don't need that I'm not gonna sneak
screw that get out here
sneaking who needs sneaking I gotta give
her back her cuffed boots armor and gone
let's get rid of these and weapons blah
blah blah blah blah blah Blee don't care
don't care give me your potions all of
them just minor douche douche
all right I think that's all okay if
that's all I got and I guess huh steel
greatsword
wait no yes wait no yes is ma yeah wait
I'm trying to remember how much damn in
my axe have ai ai ai ai I don't care I
want it I want it I want it I had a
little more dinner I don't care I don't
care I want it I want it I want it come
on Lydia
all right guess I should put Lydia's
armor back on I suppose I'm right behind
you here what do you want me to carry
yeah yeah yeah here's your stuff back
there you go steel armor cut boot what
Oh No yeah steel armor cuff boots and
Imperial gauntlets there you go happy
now
we give you shield hello al for her
nooblet the finest weapons and armor
probably not the finest but good job
talking it up there it is steel shield
damn it as expensive ah I hope she
appreciates this golly it's not even
that much armor it's actually uh ah but
she can block with it all right whatever
if it's keeping her alive I need a
better assistant anyway J assistant here
what do you want me to carry chimera
yeah I got you a present oh yeah how do
you show your appreciation
that's art going then now you travel to
Whiterun Whiterun is a name that I can
never remember and we get more potions
if I have enough money which I probably
don't among the Companions most
treasured artifacts are the fragments of
with' rod oh man what weird names is be
blind
they are all from Skyrim
the Nords and whatnot okay where's the
potion guy oceans oceans potions potions
potions potions our Acadias cauldron
okay once I get the potions that I can
go to the thingamabob the Horn of
Joramun Gor
and then then I can go junk or wasn't
that like a mob in rather pale could be
ataxia uh it's quite a problem back I'm
a freakin Argonian okay what have you
ever look potions healing yes oh my god
they cost so much
I I don't I got I don't have I don't
have
what about schema can I sell you scum
huh why can't that be damn it all right
I need a vacuum fine freakin gold I'm
poor I'm friggin fraggin poor and
whatever I'm really glad that menu thing
is gone I don't know what I did duh
change it but I'm really really happy
don't care kid shut up shut up shut your
face shut your face okay
now we had to know her yeah we had to up
there more Thal um looks like alright um
see the by Dawn star Leo's bow that's
all about anyway looks like if we go to
more Thal
damnit um all the stables there's a
there's a stable guy that'll take us
there I got this I know exactly what I'm
doing the best techniques are bops
never mind then I don't have enough and
buy a horse there we go there it is oh
my god huh whoa that's that guy took
your clothes he was just that's a guy
who's floating there before but now he's
dead okay I need to go to the right wall
where do you want to go if I have enough
money
hmm wha why aren't you gonna Marth all
see ya
screw you alright what was that other
place then don't tell me that I have to
run all the way let's try Dawnstar
I can take you to where do you want to
go damn it
alright solitude was the other one I
meant back and we'll be off okie dokie I
can't wait here forever come on Lydia
come aboard sit next to me I guess I'm
just gonna be walkin go go such an
inconvenience no there's not even any
text at all on this all right where am I
there's the marker okay off we go come
on Lydia we got stuff to do
again more running oh I don't even have
my my item equip my weapon my new steel
great sword yeah oh I got a swim well
good thing I'm good at swimming at all
who are you who the hell are you
Oh your guard let's see come on Lydia
you're gonna be an Argonian yet bloosh
it's so
oh hello Lydia you are swimming good for
you good for you can't breathe
underwater though but that's okay yeah
that's okay let's see what we got here
new ingredients there's all sorts of
different ingredients in the swamp
firewood I don't want firewood
screw that oh oh that mud crab Oh looks
like you took care of it Lydia good job
putting that new shield to work listen
more stuff over here man 90% of this
game is it's gonna be meat picking
flowers dick dude Oh
fireflies gimme gimme rip apart Jeremy
Jeff give give wait was that hell why is
there battle music hello whoa
Lydia where'd you find a spider oh yeah
so tough oh good job
where are they Oh another mud crab oh
hello
I should get the dapper mud crab mod the
one that puts the top hat in the monocle
on the mud crabs that is the best mod
ever right way
moving forward come on I gotta find the
horn of yabba Norvin jar stray bow Slama
JAMA ramrod Hamm stray hmm
whatever yeah I'm not even gonna make it
ooh rabbit I don't care I'm trying to
make it to my destination death Bell mmm
things are not going fast enough I need
a horse but to need to get a horse I
need money get money I need to go
adventuring but to get to the adventure
ah shut up Lydia I'm sorry I yelled I'm
sorry I'm just a little testy and what
do you know that's all the time I got
for this episode sorry I didn't make
much progress learned a word oh I got
whirlwind sprint why didn't I use that a
would yeah anyway thanks you thanks you
thank you everybody for watching hope
you enjoyed it and as always I will see
you in the next part bye-bye